we have with this new york times article
from ben smith it's really interesting
he mentions
that our media operates like election
commissions
when when we're trying to figure out who
actually won
we we go about this in a really weird
way the news outlets just tell us and we
assume they're telling the truth
even though they're just making
predictions
isn't that weird yeah yeah i mean i
always assume i guess
weird isn't isn't what i would use the
the term
well i always assumed that like the
official reporting coming into the the
news outlets was that
they would hear from like the state
election board saying we've confirmed
this is the results
that's not the case they're taking like
polling data and they're making phone
calls and then saying here's
our projection hey who did you vote for
hey who did you vote for who did you
vote for
is that is that what they're saying what
they do because who's going to tell them
trump no one's going to say that well
we've known that well they do well they
did they did in 2016 right they didn't
want to
and they do call the election boards but
ultimately it's just like
they're not certified results and so
what ends up happening is we had the
very famous 2000 moment
where fox news called florida for george
bush but then everyone said he didn't
and they were like wait what happened
and then al gore rescinded his his
concession and then it went to the
courts and then bush won
okay because the media is telling us who
won
great instead of us like waiting a week
we created the spectacle where the day
of election
now we're not going to have that and so
no one trusts the media either
anymore so you know that's not going to
work
anyway this story here from the boston
globe
is is this this is actually
relatively old story it's from june but
we're getting new information
on a bipartisan group secretly gathering
to game out
a contested trump biden election and it
wasn't pretty they say
i can go through all the details but
suffice to say it's very very simple
all of the scenarios result in street
level violence political impasse
the law is essentially helpless they
predicted four scenarios
one in which trump wins but only with
their electoral college
and in that scenario joe biden would
not concede well and and
you you said this earlier all of the
people that are in this group doing this
don't like trump at all yeah they're all
never trump correct right all of them
yeah so what's really interesting is
actually this op
this column from ben smith over the new
york times how the media would get the
election story wrong
we may not know the results for days and
maybe weeks so it's time to rethink
election night
i don't think there's going to be an
election night or even election month
right now in new york city they're still
trying to count
the mail-in ballots from six weeks ago
and they don't know who won these
primaries the mail in ballots
[Music]
sounds like there's something fishy with
mail-in ballots but check take a look at
how the column ends and then
we'll talk about you know what this
means in terms of these scenarios they
say
conveniently a group of former top
government officials called the
transition integrity project
actually gained four possible scenarios
including one that doesn't look that
different
different from 2016 a big popular win
for mr biden
and a narrow electoral defeat presumably
reached after weeks of counting the
votes in pennsylvania
for their war game they cast john
podesta who was hillary clinton's
campaign chairman in the role of mr
biden
they expected him when the votes came in
to concede
just as mrs clinton had the only issue
yeah he didn't mr podesta playing biden
shocked the organizers by saying he felt
his party wouldn't let him concede
alleging voter suppression he persuaded
the governors of wisconsin and michigan
to send pro-biden electors to electoral
college
presumably at odds with what the results
actually were
in that scenario california oregon and
washington then
threatened to secede from the united
states if mr trump took office as
planned
the house named biden president the
senate and white house stuck with trump
at that point in the scenario the nation
stopped looking to media outlets for
cues
and waited to see what the military
would do oh
so here's the scenario i have what
happens when
fox news says donald trump has won
and then msnbc says joe biden has won
and the results are insanely different
and then so then what you just said you
had it you you go
what what do you think well then you end
up with
this scenario exactly as they said it
there the left is going to argue we
didn't lose we won the
it's reported in the press fox news is
fake news
and then fox is going to report it for
trump and then the people are going to
say msnbc cnn these are fake outlets
you're going to have all the liberals
saying there's no way all of these
outlets are fake
right-wing media is lying the la joe
biden and his camp are gonna say
right-wing media is just trying to
they're fascists trying to support trump
and you're gonna end up
with people who actually read the news
who actually know the data
are going to be called right wing and it
won't matter what you believe or what
you don't believe
i think the military will side with
trump
i think i think so i think i think so
but it's hard to know for sure we've
already had several you know former
generals come out against him
and slam him that doesn't mean anything
they're
former like the the military right now i
mean i personally know people that are
fed up with what's happening
saying i'm sick of the democrats i'm
sick of what's going on
and i'm just i think they'd side with
him
they side with the president well we
need to see how the election goes
but there's an even worse scenario not
listed in any of these games
and that's an election night in-person
polling landslide for trump
that they refuse to call because of
mail-in ballots
and then over the course of a few weeks
ballots keep pouring in
and it flips for biden 550 million votes
for biden it's like there's there's only
350 million
americans it could be something like
trump gets 64 million
and they're like you know or because of
mainland voting it would go
it would be split between trump and
biden but they'll be like 50 million
votes cast for trump and 40 million for
biden
it's it looks like it should be a
landslide but we still have mail-in
ballots so we're not gonna call it
tonight
and then every week biden gets you know
three or four million and trump gets
like a half a million and then
in the span of like three or four weeks
all of a sudden joe biden is now
the winner and then no matter what
happens trump's like where are these
ballots coming from how is this possible
where did all these votes come from it
won't matter well they keep printing uh
dollars probably they keep printing
ballots just
keep printing ballots we'll be good the
crazy thing is that this did happen in
2018
but the republicans didn't contest it so
there were races
so here this is an interesting thing i
often talk to talk about how i was wrong
in 2018.
okay maybe i wasn't depending on how
conspiratorial you want to get
go on so i thought the republicans were
going to dominate they controlled every
branch of everything basically
and i was like considering this insanity
that we're seeing in the press in cancel
culture
i can't imagine that you know the house
would flip you know this blue wave would
really hit
conservatives basically won for the most
part ver
in the initial reporting and then i
basically i made a video saying there
was it was a red wave there was no blue
wave yeah but then over the next several
days to a week or whatever
new votes just started popping in and
then all of a sudden the races started
flipping in favor of democrats hmm
trump said that this would happen and
and you know basically
i don't know the exact uh tweets he put
out but something alluding to
you know interference fraud or whatever
but then when they all won
no one of the republicans tried to stop
it nobody filed suit it just accepted it
as
you know that's what happened and then
of course the democrats with their new
house majority
tried to impeach the president yeah and
then started doing a whole bunch of you
know insane
insane stuff like adam schiff published
private details of an american
journalist without a warrant
that's messed up he yeah he used the
subpoena power of congress and i guess
judicial judicial watch challenged them
and they lost like the
congress is allowed to seize a private
citizen's personal information phone
records and publish them
with no consequence that's messed up wow
take a look at this from uh from the new
york times they say
ben smith writes i spoke last week to
executives tv hosts and election
analysts
across leading american newsrooms and i
was struck by the blithe confidence
among some top managers and hosts
who generally said they've handled
complicated elections before and can do
so again
and i was alarmed by the near panic
among some of the people playing
paying close attention the analysts and
producers trying and often
failing to get answers from state
election officials about how
and when they will count the ballots and
report results the nerds are freaking
out
said brandon finnegan the founder of
decision desk hq which delivers election
results to media outlets
i don't think it's penetrated enough in
the average viewer's mind that there's
not going to be an
election night the usual razzmatazz of a
panel sitting around
discussing election results that's dead
so uh how many buildings are going to
get burned down on november 4th
november third i mean i was just in uh
philadelphia yesterday and
half of the buildings i was i mean i was
driving down the street half the
buildings were boarded up
they all had you know black lives matter
stuff written on the outside of the
boards and all i can see is like man
they're just
pleading not to burn their business down
that's all i can see
it's it's scary everybody black lives
mafia man that's
it's actually ringing true more and more
the more we go on
it's been hijacked is what i've been
saying they put up signs saying please
don't hurt us
yep they they paint in their windows we
support you please please
they put up antifa signs i'll tell you
what man antifa's out of the question at
this point antifa
as far as i'm concerned the narrative of
antifa is over you know why why what
used to be antifa not just flies black
lives matter flags
right it's a good point they still they
still have their antifa flags but
they're wearing shirts that say black
lives matter they put up signs that say
black lives matter
yeah it's the shield yeah the shields
say black lives matter
so they're no longer anti for now now
there is an organization
congratulations they like to say antifa
isn't actually
an organization okay black lives matter
is they receive funding
and the people running around with
shields have black lives matter
written on them they received funding
and they extort businesses that's right
have any of the and and overtly as black
lives matter now here's the important
question has any of these black lives
matter organizers
with these massive protests in portland
oregon denounced the explosives being
used
not that i know not that i know of maybe
they did if they did then you know
thank you i'm glad but i don't think
they did so here's what i would say
there's going to be
some testimony before congress about
antifa
and that's wrong andy noah is going to
be testifying among other people
wrong wrong wrong the people in portland
they can claim to be antifa they may
have been anti-from the past
but the 60 nights of violent riots was
under the banner of black lives matter
that's true
and i'm not saying that to be uh to
agitate or to be emotional
literally they have shields that say
black lives matter on them yeah they put
uh post like uh bills like paper flyers
on the fencing saying black lives matter
it's reported in the press they're
protesting for
george floyd and four black lives matter
then black lives matter has a national
organization that raises tons of money
they have high profile personalities and
have any of them called this out
in fact when it came to the dude in
louisville who's being extorted
they actually came out attacking the
business owner for trying to resist the
extortion attempt
has anyone from the parent organization
condemned the extortion going on in
louisville
not that i've seen yeah and that could
just be me it could be the media to be
fair
but not that i've seen in which case the
conversation
needs to be put forth that black lives
matter needs to stop the violence the
explosives the weapons
and there's even naacp leaders calling
this
out in oregon specifically there's one
guy
who was saying that this whole event has
become a white spectacle it was supposed
to be about black lives matter and now
they've just taken the whole thing over
numerous numerous um uh black activist
leaders have been saying
that the far left has co-opted black
lives matter now you have overt marxism
and the far left engaging in violence
they're not flying the antifa flag
anymore
so that needs to be pointed out and if
they have a problem with that then you
need to call out the violent extremists
who are flying your flag and being
extremists
there's no excuse you got to do it
so the interesting thing that ben smith
brings up is that the media for some
reason takes the place of national
election commissions
he says here the media actually
assembles the results from 50 states
tabulates them and declares a victor and
we can't really help ourselves
the media establish establishes the
narrative to explain what happened
he then goes on to talk about how this
resulted in you know 2000 with gorvy
bush and all stuff
and then he basically brings up the
point that they don't know what's going
to happen
many of these people have have not woken
up to the fact
that there's not going to be an election
a lot of the people who work at say like
cnn and msnbc and all that
seem to think that the companies that
provide them data are able and ready and
they're not
so i can only imagine that you're gonna
see like wolf blitzer standing there and
he's gonna be like
no data coming in and we're five hours
in
still no data and then it's like four in
the morning and it's like zero percent
across the board
nothing nothing happens no election
night yep
so then what do we do as a country oh i
wish i had all the answers
i don't i don't have any of them anybody
know i know what we do
buy buy uh branch buy buy gold buy
bitcoin buy a ranch
yeah buy a workout van yeah get out of
cities i guess
yeah i don't know everyone's getting
armed that's true you got record gun
sales
i wonder i really wonder about this you
know i was thinking about we
we talk a lot about the potential for
war and stuff
and maybe we can talk about this in in a
bit like in a fuller segment but i was
curious like
we've got people decentralizing our
economy by leaving cities
yeah we've got people buying weapons
people buying gold
people buying stocks and interestingly
it's it's like these things would
greatly benefit us
in a in a war but the other thing i
realized too is that with the economy
taking a massive hit i wonder
if we're going to reach every enlistment
goal for every branch of the armed
forces
i don't know i'm not i'm not you know i
could be wrong about this my
understanding is that
basically when the economy does bad
enlistment skyr enlistment skyrockets
because
it's a guaranteed job so i wonder if
this will still end up benefiting us
as well there's talk talks floating
around thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you